part of the
reason for the taboo on psychedelics in
the present society is because
to experience these things is to
practice
democracy
on a dangerous level
it's almost like free thinking carried
to an unbearable
level from the point of view of the
state
the other night i was on mushrooms and
these things go on
which are you say to yourself
that's a thought that i just had but you
have the feeling that everybody from
seattle to san diego must have just hit
the floor and said my god what was that
the notion that what you just witnessed
went on between your ears
seems preposterous because the the
display of energy release is
is much greater than anything you as an
individual will ever witness i mean they
tell you atomic bombs are strong they
tell you all these things but you will
probably never witness a more energetic
phenomenon then this thing which can go
on with your eyes closed between your
ears in a quiet room in the middle of
the night and i think that energy
is our energy the energy of the questing
individual and it's awesome
awesome to the questing individual
awesome to any social organization that
would like to
row its boat without coming to terms
with that and this is why i think you
know at the close of the neolithic
shamanism had to be bridled in and over
a period of four or five millennia it
was squeezed down to cult sites
where
a group of initiates dispensed a mystery
seasonally and
in other words there was a steady
constriction of access to this kind of
knowledge and it's only really with the
rise of a kind of crypto anarchy like
the united states where so much freedom
is allowed that left to our own devices
and with the vast libraries we're able
to pour through
some few of us come upon
these things and exercise our right to
explore it there are very few societies
where this would be tolerated for a
moment it probably wouldn't be tolerated
in this society if the high sheriffs had
any notion what this energy is that
we're actually tickling
so
what i'm trying to say and what i
gathered from what i heard here is
there's a sense that it is important
and i share that sense and one of the
things i always puzzle over when i take
it is say people have been doing this
for 50 000 years and yet they were never
able to boot it out into the mainstream
and make something out of it is it
always to be simply a private
mind-boggling mystery isn't there some
way that the affirmation
and the information and the sense of
unifying organic power that it carries
could be
surfaced and talked about
and i think the the answer is yes but
slowly
and the key is talked about
that what we're involved in here and why
uh
roy plays my tapes with such devotion
is we have to create a language
that is a language specific to this
thing
because using the language of
yogic extesis
saint john of the cross
or the language of phenomenological
psychology it's not doing it for us
and my
probes into description
if they
obtain a resonance from people it's
because they sound like
we're beginning to make a little bit of
progress
the problem is in order to make a little
bit of progress we have to say such
outlandish things that it seems like
we're
making a complete break with reason
i mean john mentioned this evening the
extraterrestrials i mean what are we to
make of these voices
and presences and information dispensing
hierophanies of occult knowledge that
are contacted this stuff has been
psychopathy
for 500 years in the definitions of
western civilization
so
a radical restructuring of consciousness
and to me that means of language is
going to be necessary to let this in
and
the conclusion i draw from the 60s
looking at what leary said
and hoffman and other people
was they always said
what had made them think
like leary produced systems
about the molecular memory that this
memory that memory i
have i've produced systems and tomorrow
i will expose some of you the people who
come to the afternoon session to one of
them
but i don't take them very seriously
they see because language itself is very
mutable you can say anything
about the psychedelic experience and if
you say it
well
people will say yes that's it
that's it
so
you know what is it aside from that and
that's what i want to try and get at to
build a consensus and it's taken a long
time
for there to even be the notion of a
need to build a consensus because we're
talking it's like trying to build a
consensus about what is an orgasm
except we're building it with a much
smaller sample of people who have ever
had this experience you know
i mean uh
so we're trying to map an experience
which some people have had a little bit
of some people have had a lot of but
everyone who's ever passed near it
by and large is convinced that they know
what it is
so
a language has to be produced that is uh
self-reflective of the experience now
how do we know when we've achieved that
well the only thing i can say about that
is
william blake had an interesting rap
which was he said the truth cannot be
told so as to be understood
without being believed
in other words if you say the truth and
someone understands what you're saying
they will automatically believe you they
will have no choice but to believe you
because to hear it and understand it is
to believe it and so it's that kind of
talk going back and forth between us
the hearing
that which you must believe because it
is so obviously true and then saying it
back to other people that will create a
consensus
when i first began
public speaking two or three years ago
my main concern was to call attention
to this phenomenon of the super ego or
the extraterrestrial
because i just thought that was the
damnedest thing you know i mean i had
taken lsd and all kinds of things and
had a fair notion of how consciousness
should map and there just was no place
in it
for
elves dispensing advice in rhyming
couplets
and
you know that
i i thought that i could tell people if
you take five grams of mushrooms in the
dark this will happen to you
and then they would do that
and then they would say
you're right
and then somehow my work would be
finished because i would have pointed to
a phenomenon other people would have
confirmed it and then
though the powers which explain these
things would bend over it and figure it
all out and take it away from you and me
and go off and explain it back to us and
i've discovered that
as my friend eric yanch always insisted
to me
that knowledge is meta stable
you cannot
really
change
the nature of knowledge even if you're
shouting from the rooftops
so now i have said this
many people have confirmed that it is so
and it don't mean [ __ ] as far as i can
tell to the rest of the world
so i've become interested in something
else
which is what's it like to be people who
know this in a world where everyone else
thinks you're crazy in other words what
is it like to cultivate a point of view
about reality that is intolerably at
odds
with the
the
larger
ideological climate in which you're
embedded
and i think it's a riot i think maybe
this is
this is the real payoff on the uh on the
psychedelic experience is the permission
to exemplify a kind of harmless madness
you know
and
it gives
us
great happiness
which i never that was not what i set
out for what i set out for was to
as i used to say you know open the door
to hyperspace and let it all flow in
well maybe this is happening maybe we
collectively are doing it or that it
will be done between now and the
century's turn but i think
far more than i expected the source of
our own happiness as people
lay very close to the surface in
everything that we were doing
so i think
you know
we all have traveled this path by
different routes
and now we've arrived here
and this
is however uh
turgid and obscure
a
view you may have from this high
pinnacle this is nevertheless someplace
quite far along i think i mean i think
this is the path with heart
and i've
mostly by dumb luck
kept to it and everyone that i have seen
keep to it has
been lifted up
but you have to
[Music]
make many discriminating judgments
along the way and know actually what it
is that you're after
and
so it isn't you know stimulation or
depression
or
a fix i don't think anybody here is
neurotic so we're not talking about
psycholytic drugs or drugs which make
your day-to-day life tolerable and
probably all our day-to-day lives are
tolerable what we're talking about is
actually chance taking excursions into
other dimensions
so it's more a warrior or not that has a
bad
taste it's more an explorer
kind of
of stance
[Music]
[Music]
you